- [Helga] Arnold!
- [Narrator] Remember your favorite
football shaped cartoon from the ’90s?
Well, this is Craig Bartlett, the
non-football shaped creator of Hey Arnold!
So we thought we'd ask him
a few things about the show.
But before we start, Craig,
can you do what you do best?
- So do you want me to, uh,
just start drawing Arnold?
- [Narrator] We sure do.
- Alright, here we go.
(suspenseful music)
When I designed Arnold in the first place,
I was really trying to make him stand out.
I always remember what Matt Groening told me,
he said, “You should
try to make them so that
they work in silhouette or
really small on the screen."
So that's how it started;
Arnold was a little clay
football shaped head because it was funny.
- Move it, football head!
- Hey Arnold!
- It was just me trying
to be kinda radical.
Pigeon man, that is a pet peeve of mine.
- [Narrator] In one
episode, Arnold meets the
lonely pigeon man and at
the end of the episode...
- Where will you go?
- Somewhere I can live
in peace with my friends.
- [Narrator] Well, the internet
had some ideas about that.
- Somebody said it's a suicide story,
that he jumps off the building
and Arnold in his mind
to make sense out of it,
imagines that he flew away.
I hate that, we wrote what we wrote
because I wanted him to fly away,
I always imagine pigeon
man going to Paris next,
where he helps pigeons in Paris.
I just really wanna set
the record straight,
pigeon man is not a
suicide story, he's fine.
I wanted to make Hey Arnold! have
a really detailed specific vibe of a city
that was kinda ugly but beautiful.
Arnold's city is based on
where I grew up in Seattle
and also, where I went
to art school in Portland
but it's also based on
Brooklyn with all the stoops
and the brownstones, so
it's really a kind of a
collage of several northern cities.
When people talk about what
they like best about the show,
the room comes up over and over again,
which is a super cool
attic with the skylight
and then he can climb right
up the stairs on the wall
and open the window of his skylight
and go down the fire
escape and we were reading,
Gabriel García Márquez
and One Hundred Years of Solitude
and Love in the Time of Cholera.
Those were big influences on us because
magic realism is the term coined about
García Márquez’s writing.
I wanted there to be a magical realism
to Arnold's house and his neighborhood.
- [Narrator] So Craig, one last question.
- You bet.
- [Narrator] After all those years
of making TV for kids, was it worth it?
- Making TV is incredibly powerful, you know.
Having millions of people
watch what you make on TV,
you realize what you
say, especially to a kid,
they're gonna soak that up and
they're never gonna forget it.
One of the themes in the series is that,
you know, you're kind of
trying to make the most
out of a not so good situation.
That's really what the show's about.
I'll get this really
heartfelt notes from people
and they'll say that they got strength
when things looked their worst.
What can be better than that?
That's incredibly gratifying.
- [Helga] Hey Arnold!